Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请记住遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线要小心，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Hitler had entered at Röhm's bedroom alone with a whip in his hand. Behind him had stood two detectives holding pistols with the safety catch removed at the ready. He had spat out the words, Röhm, you are under arrest! Röhm had looked up sleepily out of the pillows on his bed. Hail, mein Führer. You are under arrest. Hitler had bawled for the second time. He had turned on his heel and left the room. Meanwhile, upstairs in the corridor, things have become very lively. SA leaders are coming out of their rooms and being arrested. Hitler shouts at each one, have you had anything to do with Roms machinations? Of course,
保持警惕，注意周围环境，确保安全。希特勒独自闯入罗姆的卧室，手里拿着鞭子。在他身后站着两名侦探，手里拿着已经打开保险的枪，随时准备射击。他咆哮道：“罗姆，你被捕了！”罗姆睡眼惺忪地从枕头上抬起头。“希特勒万岁。”“你被捕了。”希特勒第二次大声吼道。他转身离开了房间。与此同时，楼上的走廊里，情况变得非常混乱。冲锋队（SA）的领导人们正从房间里出来，随即被捕。希特勒对每个人大喊：“你和罗姆的阴谋有什么关系吗？”当然，
none of them says yet, but that doesn't help them. Hitler mostly knows the answer himself. Now and then he turns to Goebbels or Lutzer with a question, and then comes his decision. Arrested. So that was Eric Kemper, who was the driver of Adolf Hitler, who was describing the morning of the 30th of June, 1934, that sees a bloody and carnivorous faction fight in the Nazi party, a faction fight that is commemorated as the Night of the Long Knives. And Dominic, this is the first kind of the as the night of the long knives um and dominic this is the first kind of the great drama really of the nazis in power isn't it and we did uh this time last year four episodes on the rise of the nazis to power and now we're going to do four episodes looking at
他们都说没有，但这无济于事。希特勒自己心里大多已有答案。他时不时地转过头问希姆莱或卢策一个问题，然后做出决定。逮捕。以上是阿道夫·希特勒的司机埃里克·肯普（Eric Kemper）对1934年6月30日那个早晨的描述，那一天见证了纳粹党内一场血腥且残酷的派系斗争，这场斗争被称为“长刀之夜”。多米尼克，这是纳粹掌权后的第一场大戏，对吧？去年这个时候我们做了四集关于纳粹崛起的节目，现在我们要用四集来探讨
the nazis in power yes uh that was a slightly inspector clusoish hitler i thought there uh tom it was german he was clearly indisputably german well of course hiller had an austrian Yes. That was a slightly Inspector Clouseau-ish Hitler, I thought there, Tom. No, he's German. He was clearly indisputably German. Well, of course, Hitler had an Austrian accent. I don't know whether you were trying to give an Austrian flavour there. Yeah, of course. Were you?
纳粹掌权后的情况。是的，汤姆，我觉得刚才那个希特勒有点像克卢梭探长。那是德语，他显然毫无疑问是德国人。好吧，希特勒当然有奥地利口音。我不知道你刚才是不是想带点奥地利风味。是的，当然。你是吗？
Yeah. Of course you were. So for those people who haven't listened to our series on the rise of the Nazis, please do. For those of you who haven't got time to do it and just want to crack on with the night of the long knives, which as Tom says, rightly, is this seismic moment in the early years of the Third Reich. I guess we'll just give a little bit of a recap of where we got to with the Nazis and their rise to power. So as we explored last time, the roots of Nazism lie in the 1880s and 1890s, in this kind of ferment of ideas, kind of social Darwinism,
是的，当然是。所以对于那些还没听过我们关于纳粹崛起系列节目的听众，请务必去听听。对于那些没时间听，只想直接进入“长刀之夜”的听众——正如汤姆所说，这确实是第三帝国早期的一个震荡时刻——我想我们还是先简单回顾一下纳粹是如何崛起的。正如我们上次探讨的那样，纳粹主义的根源在于19世纪80年代和90年代，在那段思想激荡的时期，社会达尔文主义、
obsession with racial hygiene, obsession with national degeneracy, with war, with struggle, with anti-Semitism in particular. Those ideas were very current in germany before the first world war and there are equivalents elsewhere of course with a slightly different flavor but then they became intensified i suppose turbocharged would you say tom by the great war and the experience of the war the shattering experience for germany yeah because they lose and that's the key and the fact that so many people are starving in Germany, and then they lose. Absolutely.
对种族卫生的痴迷、对民族退化的恐惧、对战争、斗争以及特别是反犹主义的痴迷。这些思想在第一次世界大战前的德国非常流行，当然在其他地方也有类似的表现，只是风味略有不同。但我认为，汤姆，这些思想在“大战”之后被强化了，或者说被“涡轮增压”了，战争对德国来说是一次粉碎性的经历。是的，因为他们输了，这是关键。而且当时德国有那么多人挨饿，然后他们输了。绝对是这样。
They lose. Germany loses a lot of territory. There is the German Revolution in 1918, 1919. Total chaos on the streets. The Kaiser is kicked out. Fears of Bolshevism. And in this atmosphere, lots of little paramilitary parties and things flourish. One of them is the German Workers' Party, the National Socialist
他们输了。德国失去了大片领土。1918年到1919年发生了德国革命。街头一片混乱。德皇被赶下台。人们对布尔什维克主义感到恐惧。在这种氛围下，许多小型准军事政党和组织蓬勃发展。其中之一就是德国工人党，即后来的国家社会主义
Party, as it becomes. And this attracts a former corporal in the Bavarian army who had previously been born in Austria, who is Adolf Hitler, who discovers that he has this brilliant gift of the gab, that he's able to articulate all the rage and resentment of former servicemen who feel betrayed by the end of the war. And in particular, his guiding principle is antisemitism, the antisemitism that he had learned as a young man in Vienna before the First World War. And he now develops this entire worldview based on war and struggle and racism, and in particular, antisemitism. And the Nazis tried a failed putsch in 1923. Obviously, it didn't work out. Hitler was briefly imprisoned. But they profit from a couple of things. In other circumstances,
党。这吸引了一位曾在巴伐利亚军队服役、出生于奥地利的下士，他就是阿道夫·希特勒。他发现自己拥有出色的口才，能够表达出那些因战争结束而感到被背叛的前军人们的所有愤怒和怨恨。特别是，他的指导原则是反犹主义，这是他在第一次世界大战前在维也纳年轻时学到的。他现在发展出了一套基于战争、斗争、种族主义，特别是反犹主义的世界观。纳粹在1923年发动了一场失败的政变。显然，这没成功。希特勒被短暂监禁。但他们从几件事中获利。在其他情况下，
they would have remained an extreme, eccentric, radical party. But they profit from the fact that the new republic that's been set up in Germany in the 1920s, the Weimar Republic, lacks legitimacy from the start in the eyes of a lot of conservative Germans, that so many conservative Germans and middle-class Germans and whatnot are terrified of communism, of Bolshevism and disorder. It's not just that they don't believe the Weimar Republic will be a bulwark against it. They actually think the Weimar Republic is riddled with it and that anything left of center is kind of crypto-communist. And then the absolutely searing impact of the Great Depression, which is worse in Germany than
他们本会一直是一个极端的、古怪的激进政党。但他们获利于这样一个事实：20世纪20年代在德国建立的新共和国——魏玛共和国——从一开始在许多保守派德国人眼中就缺乏合法性。许多保守派德国人、中产阶级德国人等等都对共产主义、布尔什维克主义和混乱感到恐惧。这不仅仅是因为他们不相信魏玛共和国能成为抵御这些威胁的堡垒。他们实际上认为魏玛共和国已经被这些思想渗透，任何中间偏左的东西都被视为某种隐秘的共产主义。然后是经济大萧条带来的极其严重的冲击，这在德国比
almost anywhere else in the world, massive unemployment. And against that background, the Nazis prosper as a kind of populist party. And then the terrible mistake that conservative elites employ Hitler effectively. They've run out of options. They're feuding with each other. They bring Hitler in as the hired gun, don't they, Tom? They do. And they appoint him chancellor at the end of January 1933. And Dominic, just to name check, some of those conservatives, because they will be playing a part in this drama.
世界上几乎任何其他地方都要严重，失业率极高。在这种背景下，纳粹作为一个民粹主义政党繁荣起来。然后是保守派精英雇佣希特勒这个可怕的错误。他们已经走投无路了。他们互相争斗。他们把希特勒当作雇佣枪手请了进来，不是吗，汤姆？确实如此。他们在1933年1月底任命他为总理。多米尼克，顺便提一下其中一些保守派的名字，因为他们将在接下来的剧情中扮演角色。
Yeah. We have the Reich president, who is an enormous bloke with a kind of walrus moustache, called H hindenburg who was a great war hero paul von hindenburg yeah war hero exactly so he is very elderly he's about 183 at this point and perhaps not entirely compos mentis then we have um an effete machiavel he's described as by michael burley um von pappen yes uh who you described as looking like a Daily Telegraph leader writer. That's right. So they're kind of operating behind the scenes. And also before Hitler, there is a general, Schleicher, Trotsky.
是的。我们有帝国总统，一个有着海象胡须的魁梧家伙，叫兴登堡，他是一位伟大的战争英雄，保罗·冯·兴登堡。是的，战争英雄，没错。所以他年纪很大了，此时大约183岁，可能神志不太清醒。然后我们还有一位被迈克尔·伯利描述为“虚弱的马基雅维利主义者”的冯·帕彭，是的，你形容他看起来像《每日电讯报》的社论撰稿人。没错。所以他们是在幕后操纵。而且在希特勒之前，还有一位将军，施莱谢尔，托洛茨基。
So let's get a description from Trotsky. He described Schleicher as a question mark with epaulettes, which I think is a great description. And he embodies an ambition perhaps on the part of of of generals for a military dictatorship yes and so is there a sense that the army as well are players in this absolutely they would quite fancy to be running the show absolutely the most plausible alternative to a nazi regime in 1933 is a right-wing nationalist army run military dictatorship or something like that,
让我们引用一下托洛茨基的描述。他把施莱谢尔描述为一个“带着肩章的问号”，我认为这是一个绝妙的描述。他体现了将军们对军事独裁的某种野心。是的，所以军队也是其中的参与者吗？绝对是，他们很想掌控局面。1933年纳粹政权最可能的替代方案是一个右翼民族主义军队领导的军事独裁政权，或者类似的东西，
maybe an alliance between the conservative business elites and the army. And there is a tension there right from the beginning in the Nazi regime. But to just finish up the recap, so the very last episode of our Rise of the Nazis series, we described how as soon as Hitler becomes chancellor, he unleashes this wave of violence on the streets
也许是保守派商业精英和军队之间的联盟。纳粹政权从一开始就存在这种紧张关系。但为了结束回顾，我们“纳粹崛起”系列的最后一集描述了希特勒一上台，就通过他的冲锋队
through his stormtroopers. We'll come to the stormtroopers in a little bit, who are his paramilitary kind of militia. Events play massively into his hands. An anarchist burns down the Reichstag, a Dutch anarchist, which is the parliament building. Hitler uses this as an opportunity to push through an emergency decree
在街头掀起了暴力浪潮。我们稍后会谈到冲锋队，他们是他的准军事民兵。事件的发展极大地对他有利。一名荷兰无政府主义者烧毁了国会大厦。希特勒利用这个机会推动通过了一项紧急法令，
that allows him to suspend civil liberties. He wins an election, and then he intimidates the Reichstag, the parliament, into passing an enabling act that means he can basically rule by decree outside the constitution without the Reichstag having any say in the matter. And that is then followed by a huge purge of institutions and a kind of Nazification of German life with everything from universities, I mean a university is actually leading the charge, students burning books and so on, to things like rifle clubs and hobbyist groups becoming Nazified. So already by the summer of 1933, you are well on the way to the formation of a totalitarian state. And the communists have
允许他中止公民自由。他赢得了一场选举，然后恐吓国会通过了《授权法》，这意味着他基本上可以在国会没有任何发言权的情况下，绕过宪法通过法令进行统治。随后是对各机构的大规模清洗，以及德国生活的“纳粹化”，从大学（实际上是大学带头，学生焚书等等）到步枪俱乐部和业余爱好小组，都变得纳粹化了。所以到1933年夏天，你已经在通往极权国家的道路上走得很远了。而共产党人已经
been banned. The other parties have kind of purged themselves, have voted themselves into liquidation. Concentration camps have been opened. The rule of law is imploding. So all in all, it's looking like springtime for Hitler and Germany, you might say, to coin a phrase. Very good. Yeah, exactly. But to sort of start to dig deeper into the story. So by the summer of 1933, for a lot of ordinary Germans, if you're not a communist or a keen social democrat or homosexual or, you know… A Jew. A Jew, exactly. Above all, a Jew.
被取缔。其他政党也进行了自我清洗，投票解散了自己。集中营已经建立。法治正在崩溃。总而言之，可以说这对希特勒和德国来说是“春天”，借用一句名言。非常好。是的，没错。但为了深入挖掘这个故事，到1933年夏天，对于许多普通德国人来说，如果你不是共产党人、热心的社会民主党人、同性恋者，或者……犹太人。犹太人，没错。尤其是犹太人。
You may well think that actually this has worked out all right. There is a sense that you have finally a stable government, a sense of energy and activity that is coming from Berlin. So from that perspective, you know, Hitler has that perspective, Hitler has got his enabling act, he's done well in the elections, things are looking good. The problem for him is that there are massive tensions, as you've alluded to, within the Nazi regime from the very beginning. So on the one hand, there's a lot of people who think the Nazis should be a radical movement, that they should utterly change german society sweep away the old order and create a new germany and kind of new men and women
你很可能会认为这其实还不错。人们感觉到终于有了一个稳定的政府，感觉到从柏林传来了一种活力和行动力。所以从那个角度来看，希特勒已经获得了《授权法》，他在选举中表现出色，情况看起来不错。对他来说的问题是，正如你所提到的，纳粹政权内部从一开始就存在巨大的紧张关系。一方面，有很多人认为纳粹应该是一个激进运动，他们应该彻底改变德国社会，扫除旧秩序，创造一个新德国，以及某种新男人和新女人
um to live in it these are this is their kind of it sounds a diabolical thing to say but them almost this sort of idealistic side of nazism and then the other side of the coin is that this kind of national conservative old elites the army and so on who think well we're basically running the show and we don't like all this sort of disorder and stuff because dominic the cabinet yes although hitler's chancellor there are very few kind of nazis in it aren't there most of them are still people in wing collars and yeah all that kind of stuff if you see hitler with cabinet, I was watching a documentary last night. If you see Hitler and his cabinet
来生活在其中。这听起来是一个很邪恶的说法，但这几乎是纳粹主义中某种“理想主义”的一面。而硬币的另一面是那些国家保守派旧精英、军队等等，他们认为“好吧，我们基本上在掌控局面，我们不喜欢这种混乱”。因为多米尼克，内阁里，是的，虽然希特勒是总理，但里面几乎没有什么纳粹分子，不是吗？大多数人仍然是穿着硬领衬衫的人，诸如此类。如果你看到希特勒和内阁，我昨晚在看一部纪录片。如果你看到希特勒和他的内阁
walking through the streets in January 1933 or February 1933, there are a whole load of men in top hats who look like kind of Wall Street bankers or something. And there are times when Hitler appears wearing top hats, aren't there? Absolutely.
在1933年1月或2月走在街上，有一大群戴着高礼帽的人，看起来像华尔街银行家之类的。而且希特勒有时也会戴高礼帽，不是吗？绝对是。
And then the next day he'll be wearing his brown shirt. So he's kind of playing, he's riding both horses. So this riding both horses is proving increasingly difficult for Hitler. And you mentioned the brown shirt. So the brown shirts, the SA, the Sturmabteilung as they're called, they become an increasing problem for Hitler as 1933 goes on.
第二天他就会穿上他的棕色衬衫。所以他是在玩两面派，他骑在两匹马上。所以这种骑两匹马的做法对希特勒来说变得越来越困难。你提到了棕色衬衫。所以棕色衬衫，即冲锋队（SA），正如他们所称的那样，随着1933年的推移，他们成了希特勒越来越大的问题。
So what are they? They had begun as bizarrely the gym and sports section of the Nazi party. This was a kind of euphemism describing his squad of bouncers that he used at his meetings in the 1920s. And they end up with a much better name. They end up being called the storm section, which sounds much more glamorous and exciting. It's very good for attracting young men who like action and want to kind of punch up the darling storms as unity mitford called them i knew this was going to come up unity mitford's a great fan isn't she so uh sort of posh aristocrats who we did a podcast about who became infatuated with hitler and the and the storm troopers the storm troopers are the creation of a guy called Ernst Ruhm, who you mentioned right at the beginning. Ruhm is, he looks like such a bruiser, doesn't he? If you see photographs of him, he looks like a man who would be standing outside a nightclub with a shaven head.
那么他们是什么呢？他们最初奇怪地是纳粹党的健身和体育部门。这是一种委婉的说法，用来描述他在20世纪20年代会议上使用的保镖小队。他们最终得到了一个好得多的名字。他们最终被称为“突击队”，听起来更迷人、更令人兴奋。这对于吸引那些喜欢行动、想要打架的年轻人非常有效，就像尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford）所说的“亲爱的突击队”。我知道这会提到，尤妮蒂·米特福德是个大粉丝，对吧？所以，我们做过一期关于那些迷恋希特勒和冲锋队的时髦贵族的播客。冲锋队是一个叫恩斯特·罗姆（Ernst Röhm）的人创造的，你在一开始就提到了。罗姆看起来像个打手，不是吗？如果你看他的照片，他看起来像个剃着光头站在夜总会外面的人。
Except in his last year where he looks like Uncle Monty from Withnail and I, which will mean nothing to you because I know you haven't seen it. I know, Richard Griffiths. Yes. Yes. Well, anyway. I think it's fair to say he puts on weight by the end. He definitely does. He's a man of size. The muscle turns to a bit of flap.
除了他生命的最后一年，他看起来像《我与长指甲》（Withnail and I）里的蒙蒂叔叔，这对你来说毫无意义，因为我知道你没看过。我知道，理查德·格里菲斯。是的。是的。好吧，无论如何。我认为公平地说，他到最后发福了。他确实发福了。他是个大块头。肌肉变成了一点赘肉。
He's a man of size. So the Ruhm is a veteran. He's from Munich. He's the son of a railway official. He is a veteran of the First World War. Like so many young men, he'd gone to the Western Front with great enthusiasm. A shell had blown part of his nose off. He'd been badly injured at Verdun.
他是个大块头。所以罗姆是个老兵。他来自慕尼黑。他是一位铁路官员的儿子。他是第一次世界大战的老兵。像许多年轻人一样，他怀着极大的热情去了西线。一颗炮弹炸掉了他部分鼻子。他在凡尔登受了重伤。
He had then joined the Freikorps, these kind of paramilitary units in the chaos of the 1920s. And then he'd been attracted to the Nazi party. And Röhm is absolutely typical of these people who are called the front generation. They absolutely romanticize and glamorize the experience of the trenches and the camaraderie.
他后来加入了自由军团（Freikorps），这是20世纪20年代混乱时期的一种准军事单位。然后他被纳粹党吸引了。罗姆绝对是那些被称为“前线一代”的人的典型。他们绝对浪漫化和美化了战壕的经历和战友之情。
Of course, that includes Hitler, right? Absolutely. But he is even more enthusiastic about violence and street fighting than Hitler. As far as Ruhemann is concerned, I think street fighting is Nazism and everything else, like the politics and discussing policy. He thinks that is boring, a waste of time, and actually a compromise with the old order.
当然，这包括希特勒，对吧？绝对是。但他比希特勒更热衷于暴力和街头斗殴。就罗姆而言，我认为街头斗殴就是纳粹主义，而其他一切，比如政治和讨论政策，他认为那是无聊的，是浪费时间，实际上是对旧秩序的妥协。
He loves cracking heads and having big fights. Because we should say that the Nazis come to power adopting a double approach. One, politically, they play the democratic games incredibly well. I mean, Hitler blazes all kinds of innovations that subsequent democratic leaders will follow, but also seizing control of the streets. And they're mainly fighting communists, but the establishment of Nazi rule means that the Nazis have irrevocably seized control of the streets as well as of the democratic institutions. Exactly as you say, Tom. There's a weird paradox
他喜欢打爆别人的头，喜欢打大架。因为我们应该说，纳粹上台时采取了双重策略。一方面，在政治上，他们极其出色地玩弄民主游戏。我的意思是，希特勒开创了各种后续民主领导人会效仿的创新，但也夺取了街头的控制权。他们主要是在与共产党人作战，但纳粹统治的建立意味着纳粹已经不可逆转地夺取了街头以及民主机构的控制权。正如你所说，汤姆。有一个奇怪的悖论
at the heart of the Nazi regime in 1933. On the one hand, they're clearly fermenting disorder on the streets. The stormtroopers are running amok, beating people up, smashing Jewish shop windows, beating Jews up, strutting around real bully boy kind of behavior. So they are responsible for disorder. On the other hand, Hitler's promise to the German people is, I'm going to end disorder. I'm the person who will make Germany great again and get everything calmed down. So he's absolutely riding two horses. Now, there's been a long-running tension between the SA and the rest of the Nazi party, because the SA throughout the 1920s had become more and more a kind of party within a party. Ruhm had been in and out. So at one point, he'd actually gone off to run the...
在1933年纳粹政权的核心。一方面，他们显然在街头煽动混乱。冲锋队在横行霸道，殴打他人，砸碎犹太商店的窗户，殴打犹太人，到处炫耀，表现得像个恶霸。所以他们要为混乱负责。另一方面，希特勒对德国人民的承诺是：“我将结束混乱。我是那个会让德国再次伟大并让一切平静下来的人。”所以他绝对是在骑两匹马。现在，冲锋队和纳粹党其他部分之间长期存在紧张关系，因为冲锋队在整个20世纪20年代已经越来越成为“党中之党”。罗姆进进出出。所以有一次，他实际上跑去管理……
He went to Bolivia, didn't he? The Bolivian army, which is a very bizarre career move. So not the last Nazi to go to South America, of course. Yeah, exactly. Very good. There'd been a bit of a crisis in the SA, which we don't need to go into. They'd fallen out with some of the rest of the Nazi party, and Hitler had brought Röhm back. Now, Röhm was never...
他去了玻利维亚，不是吗？玻利维亚军队，这是一个非常奇怪的职业变动。当然，他不是最后一个去南美洲的纳粹分子。是的，没错。非常好。冲锋队内部发生了一些危机，我们不需要深入探讨。他们与纳粹党的其他部分闹翻了，希特勒把罗姆带了回来。现在，罗姆从来不是……
He's a strutting bully boy sort of man. He's kind of Mussolini-esque. Yes, I guess so. Without Mussolini's brains, actually, because Mussolini was a journalist, Röhm doesn't have any of that. But he's physically imposing. Absolutely.
他是一个炫耀的恶霸式人物。他有点像墨索里尼。是的，我想是这样。实际上没有墨索里尼的头脑，因为墨索里尼是个记者，罗姆没有那些。但他身体上很有威慑力。绝对是。
And presumably Hitler has brought Röhm back because he needs his street fighting savvy. Yes, exactly. Even though he knows that Röhm is not happy about pursuing kind of political means, that Röhm just wants to have endless fights. Get out there and have a crack at the commies. Exactly. The shadow that hangs over Röhm is that he is very flagrantly gay.
而且大概希特勒把罗姆带回来是因为他需要他的街头斗殴经验。是的，没错。尽管他知道罗姆对追求政治手段不满意，罗姆只是想没完没了地打架。出去和共产党人干一架。没错。笼罩在罗姆身上的阴影是他非常公然地表现出同性恋倾向。
Everybody knows this. Lots of Hitler's sort of cronies say to him, oh, Röhm is a terrible man, kind of carrying on with blonde-haired youths, all this stuff. This is not what a Nazi should do. And actually, Hitler gives him a bit of a pass on it because he needs Röhm and he knows that he has the loyalty of all these stormtroopers. So there is a slightly odd and unexpected twist. It's a bit like Mrs. Thatcher, very tolerant of her minister's foibles. Right. That's a comparison that I would expect from a lot of Twitter academics, but not necessarily from you.
每个人都知道这一点。希特勒的许多亲信对他说：“哦，罗姆是个可怕的人，和金发青年鬼混，所有这些事情。这不是纳粹应该做的。”实际上，希特勒对他网开一面，因为他需要罗姆，而且他知道他拥有所有这些冲锋队员的忠诚。所以有一个稍微奇怪且意想不到的转折。这有点像撒切尔夫人，对她部下的怪癖非常宽容。没错。这是一个我期望从很多推特学者那里听到的比较，但不一定是从你这里。
There you go. Woke history. The old Hitler-Thatcher comparison again, I see. You can take the child out of the 1980s, but you can't take the 1980s out of the child, right? Yeah, right. So let's fast forward to the summer of 1933. The SA, the Storm Abtyling, the Storm Troopers, have now swollen to an enormous size. Loads of people have poured into their ranks. So they now have four and a half million people who are kind of paid up, brown shirt wearing Storm Troopers.
给你。觉醒历史。又见老掉牙的希特勒-撒切尔比较，我明白了。你可以把孩子带出20世纪80年代，但你不能把20世纪80年代从孩子身上带走，对吧？是的，没错。那么让我们快进到1933年夏天。冲锋队（SA）现在已经膨胀到了巨大的规模。大量的人涌入了他们的行列。所以他们现在有四百五十万名付了会费、穿着棕色衬衫的冲锋队员。
So they've absorbed lots of other paramilitary groups and veterans groups. And so Dominic, that must be larger than the army. Far larger, because of course the army is hidebound by the Treaty of Versailles. Yeah. So the army is a shadow of its former self, and the army are very anxious about this. There's this huge paramilitary formation kind of roaming around the streets. Hitler knows that the army commanders are very, very displeased about the existence of the SA.
所以他们吸收了许多其他准军事组织和退伍军人组织。多米尼克，那一定比军队还大。大得多，因为军队当然受到《凡尔赛条约》的束缚。是的。所以军队只是其昔日影子的一小部分，军队对此非常焦虑。有这样一个巨大的准军事组织在街上游荡。希特勒知道军队指挥官对冲锋队的存在感到非常非常不满。
But there's an urgency to this now because Paul von Hindenburg, who has the absolute loyalty of the army, I mean, he is the army's great hero. And he is the president. This is the walrus. The walrus, who looks like he's made of oak or something. He's like the personification of Prussian rigor.
但现在这变得紧迫了，因为保罗·冯·兴登堡拥有军队的绝对忠诚，我的意思是，他是军队的伟大英雄。而且他是总统。这就是那个“海象”。那个看起来像是橡木做的海象。他就像普鲁士严谨的化身。
He, as you said, he's actually, I think, about 85. But as you said, he appears to be 270. And he is clearly not long for this world. And when he dies, which is going to be in the next year or two, the army may well insist that one of their people becomes head of state. And that will be a problem for Hitler. It could be a rival power focus. It could be a rival power focus. It could be somebody who could act against him and undermine his regime. And so as the SA, the stormtroopers, are kind of running amok and causing all this trouble and actually turning the army against them, that makes Hitler very nervous because Hitler knows he cannot afford to alienate the army commanders.
他，正如你所说，实际上我想他大约85岁了。但正如你所说，他看起来有270岁。而且他显然时日无多。当他去世时，也就是在未来一两年内，军队很可能会坚持要求他们的人成为国家元首。这对希特勒来说将是一个问题。这可能是一个竞争性的权力中心。这可能是一个竞争性的权力中心。这可能是某个可以对他采取行动并破坏他政权的人。所以当冲锋队在横行霸道并造成所有这些麻烦，实际上让军队反对他们时，这让希特勒非常紧张，因为希特勒知道他不能疏远军队指挥官。
What is worse is that Röhm, you know, what did you call him? Uncle Monty, crossed with a kind of- Scarface. Yeah. Because he is scarred, isn't he? He's got his nose and everything. Yeah, so a noseless Uncle Monty. Yeah, cross between Voldemort, Tom, and-
更糟糕的是，罗姆，你知道，你叫他什么？蒙蒂叔叔，加上一个……疤面煞星。是的。因为他有伤疤，不是吗？他的鼻子和所有东西。是的，一个没鼻子的蒙蒂叔叔。是的，汤姆，伏地魔和……的结合体。
Yes, and Uncle Monty, yeah. He is now saying, well, actually, Nazism has lost its figure. It's lost its radical impetus. We need a second revolution, a revolution within the revolution. He says the German revolution has fallen asleep. This is all in the summer of 1933. And there's this argument, are we going to have a permanent revolution? Are the SA going to be running amok forever?
是的，还有蒙蒂叔叔，是的。他现在说：“好吧，实际上，纳粹主义已经失去了它的形象。它失去了激进的动力。我们需要第二次革命，革命中的革命。”他说德国革命已经睡着了。这都是在1933年夏天。于是出现了这种争论：我们要进行永久革命吗？冲锋队要永远横行霸道吗？
And Hitler manages to kind of dampen this down for the remainder of 1933. But then in 1934, beginning of 1934, it all kind of kicks off again. Because Ruhm, who is so restless and is always thinking that he's being sidelined and stuff, he writes a memo. I mean, it's hard to believe that he spends much time writing memos. But anyway, he writes a memo and he sends it to the army. And he says, okay, this is my plan. I think actually the SA should just be the army.
希特勒在1933年余下的时间里设法平息了这一点。但到了1934年，1934年初，一切又开始了。因为罗姆，他如此不安，总是认为自己被边缘化了等等，他写了一份备忘录。我的意思是，很难相信他会花很多时间写备忘录。但无论如何，他写了一份备忘录并把它发给了军队。他说：“好吧，这是我的计划。我认为实际上冲锋队应该直接成为军队。”
The stormtroopers could be the army. And the traditional army, they should just train our men. We should be the defense force. Okay, and so what's Hitler's take on this? The army commanders go to Hitler and they say, oh, this is totally intolerable. This strutting bully cannot squeeze us out.
冲锋队员可以成为军队。而传统军队，他们应该只训练我们的人。我们应该是国防军。好吧，那么希特勒对此有何看法？军队指挥官去找希特勒，他们说：“哦，这完全不可容忍。这个炫耀的恶霸不能把我们挤走。”
Hitler agrees with them. He forces them to do a deal. And Röhm promises he'll behave himself. But then when Hitler goes out of the room, Röhm says to his men, he's overheard saying to his men, and I quote, what that ridiculous corporal declared doesn't apply to us. Hitler has no loyalty and we'll have to send him on leave. And if we can't do this with Hitler, we'll do it without him. So this is extraordinary.
希特勒同意他们的看法。他强迫他们达成协议。但当希特勒走出房间时，罗姆对他的手下说，他被听到对他的手下说，我引用：“那个可笑的下士所宣布的并不适用于我们。希特勒没有忠诚，我们得让他休假。如果我们不能和希特勒一起做，我们就没有他也能做。”这太非凡了。
Hitler, who is the Fuhrer to most Nazis, who is the center of the kind of Nazi cult, here is the guy who was commanding his paramilitary formation who's saying, actually, you know what? Hitler's turning out to be an obstacle to our revolution and maybe he'll have to go. Which is foolish, isn't it? Because people who oppose Hitler within the Nazi party tend not to come off very well. So there was a guy called Gregor Strasser, wasn't there? He'd been very much on the socialist wing of the National Socialists. He had started opening negotiations with the conservatives to make himself vice-chancellor. So Hitler had elbowed him out.
希特勒，对大多数纳粹分子来说是元首，是纳粹崇拜的中心，在这里，指挥他的准军事组织的人却说：“实际上，你知道吗？希特勒正在成为我们革命的障碍，也许他得走人。”这很愚蠢，不是吗？因为在纳粹党内反对希特勒的人通常下场都不太好。所以有一个叫格雷戈尔·斯特拉瑟（Gregor Strasser）的人，不是吗？他非常倾向于国家社会主义的社会主义派别。他开始与保守派进行谈判，想让自己成为副总理。所以希特勒把他挤走了。
And so presumably Hitler is now thinking, this isn't just about the balance between the stormtroopers and the army. This is about my future. Now, here's the question though. If he's going to take on the SA, what resources does he have? Because you've talked about the army, you've talked about the SA,
所以大概希特勒现在在想，这不仅仅是关于冲锋队和军队之间的平衡。这是关于我的未来。现在，问题来了。如果他要对付冲锋队，他有什么资源？因为你谈到了军队，你谈到了冲锋队，
but so far we haven't talked about the police. Yeah. So he's got the police. The police have generally been taken over. So, for example, in Prussia by Nazi officials. Prussia is the biggest German state. And the guy who's initially taken over is Hermann Goering. So he is in the cabinet as interior minister for Prussia, isn't he?
但到目前为止我们还没谈到警察。是的。所以他有警察。警察通常已经被接管了。例如，在普鲁士，被纳粹官员接管。普鲁士是最大的德国州。最初接管的人是赫尔曼·戈林。所以他是普鲁士内政部长，在内阁里，不是吗？
So there's the police. There's, of course, the army. But there's also another power centre in the Nazi regime, an emerging power centre, which is Hitler's bodyguard. And they are the SS. So they are the Schutzstaffel. So that's the protection squad, isn't it, in English? Yeah, much smaller than the strong troopers, much smaller than the SA.
所以有警察。当然还有军队。但纳粹政权中还有另一个权力中心，一个正在形成的权力中心，那就是希特勒的保镖。他们是党卫队（SS）。所以他们是“保护队”，在英语里是这样，不是吗？是的，比冲锋队小得多，比冲锋队小得多。
They are more fanatical about Nazi ideology, less into the kind of street punch. I mean, they can be very violent, but they're less into the sort of the random street punch-ups. They're a crack squad of elite men. So there's about 50,000 of them? Yeah, and they tend to be university educated. Yeah. They spend a lot of time kind of talking about anti-Semitism. I mean, the classic sort of SS person is, I mean, obviously there's Heinrich Himmler,
他们对纳粹意识形态更狂热，不太喜欢那种街头斗殴。我的意思是，他们可能非常暴力，但他们不太喜欢那种随机的街头斗殴。他们是一支精英精锐部队。所以他们大约有五万人？是的，而且他们往往受过大学教育。是的。他们花很多时间谈论反犹主义。我的意思是，典型的党卫队成员是，我的意思是，显然有海因里希·希姆莱，
who had been a previously very sickly kind of idealistic person, fascinated by the occult and stuff. There's his deputy, Reinhard Heydrich. Heydrich is the son of, I think, an opera singer or something like that. He's a brilliant violinist. A fencer like that. He's a brilliant violinist. A fencer as well. He's a brilliant fencer. A reservist in the Navy.
他以前是一个非常病态的、理想主义的人，对神秘学之类的东西着迷。还有他的副手，莱因哈德·海德里希。海德里希是，我想是一位歌剧演员的儿子之类的。他是一位出色的小提琴家。像那样的击剑手。他是一位出色的击剑手。海军预备役军人。
A very sinister man. But he has a very, very high voice. He does indeed. He's both sinister and I think slightly effeminate, isn't he, Heydrich, in his kind of very scary, sinister way. So he's head of the SS, which is kind of an elite paramilitary organization and Hitler's praetorian guard, basically. I mean, devoted to looking after Hitler personally. But Himmler has also been engaging in a kind of power grab.
一个非常阴险的人。但他有一个非常非常高的嗓音。他确实有。他既阴险，而且我认为海德里希在那种非常可怕、阴险的方式上有点女性化，不是吗？所以他是党卫队的头目，这基本上是一种精英准军事组织和希特勒的禁卫军。我的意思是，致力于照顾希特勒个人。但希姆莱也一直在进行某种权力争夺。
So he's president of the Munich police, political police commander of Bavaria. So there's this process by which intelligence and political sections in the police are being sidelined off and filled with Nazis. So Goering has been doing that in Prussia. And Goering has set... So he's detached the intelligence political sections from the main body of the Prussian police. He's filled them with Nazis and he's merged them to form the secret state police, as he calls it, the Geheimstaatspolizei,
所以他是慕尼黑警察局长，巴伐利亚政治警察指挥官。所以警察中的情报和政治部门正在被边缘化，并被纳粹分子填补。所以戈林在普鲁士一直在这样做。戈林设立了……所以他把情报政治部门从普鲁士警察的主体中分离出来。他用纳粹分子填补了它们，并将它们合并组成了秘密国家警察，正如他所称的，Geheimstaatspolizei，
so the Gestapo, as it's abbreviated to. So you're having that in Prussia, but you're also having a similar process in Bavaria and then in the other German states. And Himmler is taking control of those, isn't he? So he's empire building, as Röhm is doing, as Goering is doing. Well, actually, Tom, what happens is that Goering hands control of the Gestapo in Prussia to Himmler.
也就是盖世太保（Gestapo），缩写。所以你在普鲁士有这种情况，但在巴伐利亚和其他德国州也有类似的过程。希姆莱正在控制这些，不是吗？所以他像罗姆一样，像戈林一样，在建立帝国。好吧，实际上，汤姆，发生的事情是戈林把普鲁士盖世太保的控制权交给了希姆莱。
Yeah. Because basically, lots of these Nazis hate each other. They're all rivals of the court of Hitler. Yeah. But all of Röhm's enemies basically decide it's in their interest to team up against him to make him the scapegoat it's like bullies turning on each other and they decide one of them's going to be the scapegoat and that's and so goering and himmler and all these other people they basically decide to share out power among themselves to to sort everything out so they can move against the room but just to emphasize
是的。因为基本上，这些纳粹分子中有很多互相憎恨。他们都是希特勒宫廷的竞争对手。是的。但罗姆的所有敌人都基本上认为联合起来对付他、让他成为替罪羊符合他们的利益。这就像恶霸们互相攻击，他们决定其中一个人要成为替罪羊，那就是……所以戈林和希姆莱以及所有这些人，他们基本上决定在他们之间分配权力，以解决所有问题，这样他们就可以对付罗姆。但只是要强调，
it's not just that they are teaming up as political figures, but as figures who have manpower behind them. Yeah, as institutional figures. Because if Hitler is going to take on the SA, he obviously needs people who can, you know, wield the guns and the lorries and do the shooting and everything. He does indeed. And are the army going to be complicit in this? I mean, will the army provide help? Hitler is very anxious about the army, because by the spring of 1934 the hindenburg issue was more pressing than ever it is very clear that there are a lot of people in the kind of national conservative elites who are close to the army who are extremely anxious that after more than a year hitler is getting more and more power
他们不仅是作为政治人物联合起来，而且是作为背后有人力资源的人物。是的，作为机构人物。因为如果希特勒要对付冲锋队，他显然需要那些能够，你知道，挥舞枪支和卡车，进行射击等等的人。他确实需要。军队会参与其中吗？我的意思是，军队会提供帮助吗？希特勒对军队非常焦虑，因为到1934年春天，兴登堡问题比以往任何时候都更紧迫。很明显，在接近军队的国家保守派精英中，有很多人非常焦虑，因为一年多过去了，希特勒获得的权力越来越大，
and that he is not proving to be the kind of pliant tool that they hoped. So the classic example of this is this guy, Franz von Papen, who was chancellor a couple of chancellors ago. He's now Hitler's vice chancellor. He's a man who basically wants to turn back the clock before the First World War and have a kind of arch conservative kind of regime. And on the 17th of June, 1934, Papen gives a speech which is seen as a real threat to Hitler. It's actually an extraordinary moment in the history of the Third Reich. He says, under the German revolution, under our revolution, selfishness, lack of character, insincerity, lack of chivalry and arrogance have all flourished. He says, we can't live in a
而且他并没有证明是他们所希望的那种顺从的工具。所以这方面的经典例子是这个人，弗朗茨·冯·帕彭，他是几任总理之前的总理。他现在是希特勒的副总理。他是一个基本上想把时钟拨回到第一次世界大战之前，建立某种极度保守政权的人。1934年6月17日，帕彭发表了一次演讲，这被视为对希特勒的真正威胁。这实际上是第三帝国历史上一个非凡的时刻。他说：“在德国革命下，在我们的革命下，自私、缺乏品格、不真诚、缺乏骑士精神和傲慢都泛滥成灾。”他说：“我们不能生活在一种……”
constant state of revolution. We can't live with this constant state of unrest. And this is greatly cheered by the old order. And they say, thank God somebody's basically finally said it to Hitler. This jumped up little corporal from Austria who, you know, has got all these ghastly people running around on the streets. Hitler is furious about this. And he ends up having this summit meeting with Hindenburg and the head of the army, Furnivon Blomberg, who is his defense minister. This is on the 21st of June at Hindenburg's kind of castle, which is called Neudeck in East Prussia. And Hindenburg and Blomberg, who's the
持续的革命状态中。我们不能生活在这种持续的动荡状态中。这受到了旧秩序的极大欢呼。他们说：“感谢上帝，终于有人对希特勒说了出来。”这个从奥地利来的暴发户下士，你知道，让所有这些可怕的人在街上乱跑。希特勒对此感到愤怒。他最终与兴登堡和军队首脑维尔纳·冯·勃洛姆堡（他是他的国防部长）举行了这次峰会。这是在6月21日，在兴登堡的城堡，叫诺伊德克（Neudeck），在东普鲁士。兴登堡和勃洛姆堡（他是
head of the army, say to Hitler, listen, this has all gone too far now. All this squabbling must absolutely end. You must bring your party and your movement to heel, to order. And that there's an implicit threat there, right? Which is that if Hitler doesn't act, the army will. Then the army will, exactly. Now, meanwhile, Tom, as you said, the Gestapo, the intelligence organisations,
军队首脑）对希特勒说：“听着，这一切现在太过分了。所有这些争吵必须绝对结束。你必须让你的党和你的运动服从，回到秩序中来。”这其中有一个隐含的威胁，对吧？那就是如果希特勒不采取行动，军队就会采取行动。那么军队就会，没错。现在，与此同时，汤姆，正如你所说，盖世太保，情报组织，
the police, which are under the control of Ernst Ruhm's enemies, people like Himmler and Heydrich. And are now operating on a national level. Yes. Because there'd been no national police force under the Weimar Republic, had there? So again, this concentration of police power and of SS power on a kind of federal level is giving Hitler the opportunity to strike, presumably.
警察，都在恩斯特·罗姆的敌人的控制之下，像希姆莱和海德里希这样的人。现在正在国家层面运作。是的。因为魏玛共和国下没有国家警察部队，不是吗？所以同样，这种警察权力和党卫队权力在联邦层面的集中，给了希特勒打击的机会，大概是这样。
They go to Hitler and they say, we have evidence that Ruhm, the SA, the stormtroopers, are planning a coup against you, that you are going to be kicked out. They maybe are in league with the French and, you know, the hour is dark. It could happen any moment now. You have to move. And is this true? No, it's not true. Right. The SA were never planning a coup. There was no deal with the French. The idea that RUUM was seriously going to launch a coup, he's actually not really organized enough to do it. And I don't think he has the will to do it, Tom. But on the 27th of June, the army chiefs, Wernher von Blumberg and Walter von Reichenau, who's a very keen Nazi, they go to see Hitler and they say,
他们去找希特勒，他们说：“我们有证据表明罗姆、冲锋队、冲锋队员正在策划针对你的政变，你将被赶下台。他们可能与法国人勾结，你知道，时刻黑暗。随时可能发生。你必须采取行动。”这是真的吗？不，这不是真的。没错。冲锋队从来没有策划过政变。没有与法国人的交易。罗姆真的要发动政变的说法，他实际上并没有组织好去做这件事。而且我不认为他有这个意愿去做，汤姆。但在6月27日，军队首脑维尔纳·冯·勃洛姆堡和瓦尔特·冯·赖歇瑙（他是一个非常热心的纳粹分子），他们去见希特勒，他们说：
look, you've got to move against him. You've got to do something about this. And Hitler says, fine, I've got an idea. What I'm going to do is I'm going to get all the stormtroopers, the SA leaders, I'll meet with them. There's a lot of spa towns in this story, bizarrely. At a place called Bad Wiese, which is on Lake Tegensee, which is southeast of Munich. That's where Rome is hanging out at the moment. Rome's always going to spas with kind of blonde young men.
“看，你必须对付他。你必须对此做点什么。”希特勒说：“好吧，我有个主意。我要做的是，我要把所有的冲锋队员，冲锋队领导人，召集起来。这个故事里有很多温泉小镇，奇怪的是。在一个叫巴特维塞（Bad Wiessee）的地方，在泰根湖（Lake Tegensee）上，在慕尼黑东南部。罗姆现在就在那里闲逛。罗姆总是带着金发年轻人去温泉。”
Yeah. So it is sinister because these spa towns are kind of very dull, very bourgeois, aren't they? Faint hint of sulphur hanging in the air. And you can imagine Röhm absolutely enormous. Sweating. Sweating like a pig.
是的。所以这很阴险，因为这些温泉小镇非常沉闷，非常资产阶级，不是吗？空气中弥漫着淡淡的硫磺味。你可以想象罗姆非常巨大。出汗。像猪一样出汗。
Sweating away. Absolutely. Bright red. And a very, very kind of creepy context for the drama that is to come. With a suspiciously young youth at his side, Tom, I think is
出汗。绝对是。通红。对于即将到来的戏剧来说，这是一个非常非常令人毛骨悚然的背景。汤姆，我想身边有一个可疑的年轻小伙子是
the Ernst Röhn vibe. So Hitler says, I'm going to basically beard him in his lair. As it were. Yeah. Then the very next day, the 28th of June, bizarrely Hitler goes to a wedding in a place called Essen. Well known now,
恩斯特·罗姆的氛围。所以希特勒说，我基本上要在他的巢穴里对付他。正如他们所说。是的。然后第二天，6月28日，奇怪的是希特勒去参加了一个婚礼，在一个叫埃森（Essen）的地方。现在很出名，
Tom, to fans of board games because they have the world's biggest board game convention takes place in Essen, which is nice. Anyway, Hitler goes to this wedding reception at Essen, a Gauleiter is getting married. And at the wedding reception, he is told Hindenburg and Papen, your vice-chancellor, the spokesman for the kind of national conservative old order, they're actually plotting to have a secret meeting without you in a couple of days. And Hitler thinks, oh my God, they're about to move against me. You know, the urgency is greater than ever before. I absolutely must take this opportunity to crush all my enemies in one go.
汤姆，对于棋盘游戏迷来说，因为世界上规模最大的棋盘游戏展在埃森举行，这很不错。总之，希特勒去了埃森参加一场婚礼招待会，是一位大区长要结婚。在招待会上，他被告知兴登堡和帕彭——你的副总理，那种民族保守派旧秩序的代言人——他们实际上正密谋在几天后举行一场没有你的秘密会议。希特勒心想，天哪，他们要对我下手了。你知道，这种紧迫感比以往任何时候都强烈。我绝对必须抓住这个机会，一举铲除我所有的敌人。
So the Ruhm and the stormtroopers on one hand hand and the representatives, the conservatives on the other. And he rushes off from the wedding reception. He'd be a rubbish person to have at a wedding reception anyway, because, of course, he doesn't drink and he doesn't smoke. And he likes to be the center of attention. Like you, Tom, he's a vegetarian. Yeah. So basically, if they're all eating sausages and beer and drinking beer and having a final time. He's a real misery to have at your wedding. He's nibbling on some spinach.
所以，一方面是罗姆和冲锋队，另一方面是代表们和保守派。他从婚礼招待会上匆匆离去。反正他本来就不适合参加婚礼招待会，因为他当然不喝酒也不抽烟。而且他喜欢成为关注的焦点。像你一样，汤姆，他是个素食主义者。是的。所以基本上，如果大家都在吃香肠、喝啤酒、玩得开心，他出现在你的婚礼上真是个扫兴的人。他只在那儿啃点菠菜。
But presumably, I mean, he must hate weddings because he's not the focus. Yeah, of course. Of course. He'd be the last person I'd invite to my wedding, Tom. I mean, I had you to my wedding. I'm glad you've got that on there. You came to my wedding, but I didn't have Hitler and I wouldn't have had him. But Dominic, to be fair, when you invited me, I didn't then go storming off and order a bloodthirsty putsch.
但大概，我的意思是，他一定讨厌婚礼，因为他不是焦点。是的，当然。当然。他是我婚礼上最不想邀请的人，汤姆。我的意思是，我邀请了你参加我的婚礼。我很高兴你提到了这一点。你参加了我的婚礼，但我没有邀请希特勒，我也不会邀请他。但是多米尼克，平心而论，当你邀请我的时候，我并没有冲出去发动一场嗜血的政变。
No, you didn't. So I think the comparison can only be pushed so far, is what I'm saying. I just want that on the record. That well-known, that comparison has dogged you all your career. Anyway, so yes, Hitler races away from the wedding. He goes back to his hotel. He says, put the army on alert.
不，你没有。所以我认为这种比较只能到此为止，我想说的是。我只是想把这一点记录在案。那个众所周知的比较一直伴随着你的整个职业生涯。总之，是的，希特勒从婚礼上飞奔而去。他回到酒店。他说，让军队进入戒备状态。
We're going to move. He says to Goering, who's also at the wedding, presumably been stuffing himself with sausages. He says to Goering, go back to Berlin, prepare to deal with the conservatives. I will handle the stormtroopers in Munich. You deal with the conservatives in Berlin. The knight of the long knives, Tom, is about to get started. So let's take a break there. And when we come back, spa action. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我们要行动了。他对同样在婚礼上的戈林说，他大概一直在大吃香肠。他对戈林说，回柏林去，准备对付那些保守派。我来处理慕尼黑的冲锋队。你负责处理柏林的保守派。汤姆，长刀之夜就要开始了。那么我们在这里休息一下。回来后，会有水疗中心的行动。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听，
bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the Night of the Long Knives and Dominic, the Night of the Long Knives is approaching. But before it gets launched, we go to another spa, don't we? So we promised listeners spas, and we are absolutely fulfilling that promise. An enormous amount of this podcast is Hitler just checking into and out of various hotels. So he's been to the wedding in Essen, and now he races to a town called Bad Gordesberg
额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们正在研究长刀之夜，多米尼克，长刀之夜即将来临。但在它开始之前，我们又要去另一个水疗中心了，不是吗？所以我们向听众承诺过水疗中心，我们绝对在履行那个承诺。这个播客中有很大一部分内容是希特勒在各种酒店之间办理入住和退房。所以他去了埃森的婚礼，现在他赶往一个叫巴特戈德斯贝格的小镇，
in Westphalia, because he's gone to look at some labour camps. He's gone to inspect some labour camps in Westphalia. And then he goes to this hotel, the Rhein Hotel in Bad Godersberg, where Goebbels comes to meet him. So Goebbels, who we haven't talked about, PhD in what is it? Sort of theatre, romantic theatre or something. The propaganda minister.
在威斯特伐利亚，因为他去视察了一些劳改营。他去威斯特伐利亚视察了一些劳改营。然后他去了巴特戈德斯贝格的莱茵酒店，戈培尔在那里与他会面。所以戈培尔，我们还没谈过他，博士学位是什么？某种戏剧，浪漫戏剧之类的。宣传部长。
Malignly genius at propaganda and all that kind of thing. Exactly. And because he writes a diary, we know loads about the Third Reich through Goebbels' diaries. So he's come to this hotel, and I imagine a hotel with white tablecloths. Absolutely. A little bit shabby and very elderly waiters. I would almost certainly, Tom. And again, the faint smell of sulphur. So that's the scene.
在宣传和所有这类事情上有着邪恶的天才。没错。而且因为他写日记，我们通过戈培尔的日记了解了很多关于第三帝国的事情。所以他来到了这家酒店，我想象着一家铺着白色桌布的酒店。绝对是。有点破旧，还有非常年迈的服务员。我几乎可以肯定，汤姆。而且再次，有一股淡淡的硫磺味。这就是场景。
And Goebbels pitches up, and Goebbels says, great, we're going to do this coup, this coup, you know, within our own regime. And Hitler says, yes. Goebbels thinks it's going to be against the conservatives. And Hitler says, it's not just against the conservatives. It's also going to be against Ruhm and the stormtroopers, because I now have evidence that Ruhm is plotting with the French. And he says, you know, heads are going to roll.
戈培尔出现了，戈培尔说，太棒了，我们要发动这场政变，这场政变，你知道，在我们自己的政权内部。希特勒说，是的。戈培尔以为这是针对保守派的。希特勒说，这不仅仅是针对保守派。这也是针对罗姆和冲锋队的，因为我现在有证据表明罗姆正在与法国人勾结。他说，你知道，人头落地。
Blood will be shed. I remember we were researching this, Tom. We were on a flight to Australia. You said you'd been reading all about it and you'd come to the conclusion that Hitler was a very, Hitler was a terrible man. Hitler behaved very poorly. He did. I really did.
血流成河。我记得我们在研究这个的时候，汤姆。我们在飞往澳大利亚的航班上。你说你读了所有关于它的资料，你得出的结论是希特勒是一个非常、希特勒是一个可怕的人。希特勒表现得非常糟糕。他确实。我真的这么认为。
I mean, I had that vague impression. When you get up close, he's a terrible man. He is. I mean, if you're in a spa, you wouldn't want him turning up. That's what I'm saying. No, because I mean, his violence against his enemies, horrendous, obviously, but sort of with Hitler's twisted worldview, explicable, I suppose. But he's now using that violence and that sort of sadistic ruthlessness
我的意思是，我有那种模糊的印象。当你近距离观察时，他是个可怕的人。他是。我的意思是，如果你在水疗中心，你不会想让他出现的。这就是我想说的。不，因为我的意思是，他对敌人的暴力，显然是可怕的，但用希特勒扭曲的世界观来看，我想是可以解释的。但他现在正在使用那种暴力和那种变态的冷酷无情，
against people who have been at his side for more than a decade, partners in his movement. Because presumably he is Germany. He is the embodiment of Germany. And so therefore, people who rub him up the wrong way are rubbing Germany up the wrong way. That would be his justification, I guess. Yeah, I think so. Absolutely. And I also think there's a histrionic side to Hitler. And when he is challenged, he can't take it. And because there's an enormous amount of him working himself up into a fury and kind of spitting and foaming at the mouth in this story. So this is what he's doing in this hotel. I think that's what I conveyed in the opening passage.
针对那些在他身边待了十多年的人，他运动中的伙伴。因为大概他就是德国。他是德国的化身。因此，那些让他不爽的人就是在让德国不爽。我想这就是他的理由。是的，我想是的。绝对是。而且我也认为希特勒有做作的一面。当他受到挑战时，他无法接受。而且因为在这个故事中，他有大量的时间让自己陷入狂怒，并喷着唾沫、口吐白沫。所以这就是他在酒店里做的事情。我想这就是我在开篇段落中传达的内容。
Absolutely. With the Clouseau voice. Yeah. It wasn't Clouseau. It was Austrian. It was Austrian. Okay. Overnight, 29th of June, 30th of June,
绝对是。用克鲁索探长的声音。是的。那不是克鲁索。那是奥地利口音。那是奥地利口音。好吧。一夜之间，6月29日到6月30日，
Hitler flies to Munich and he takes a whole load of adjutants and bodyguards and he also takes Goebbels with him. And they land in Munich. Rumors of this have obviously traveled around Germany that something is coming. Some kind of confrontation between the stormtroopers and the rest of the party. And some of the stormtroopers have gone berserk already. And have kind of been rampaging around the city, demonstrating. I mean, they've apparently been shouting in Munich, the Fuhrer is against us, the Reichswehr, the army, is against us. SA, come out on the streets. Show your defiance.
希特勒飞往慕尼黑，他带了一大批副官和保镖，他还带上了戈培尔。他们降落在慕尼黑。关于这件事的传言显然已经在德国传开了，有什么事情要发生了。冲锋队和党内其他成员之间某种形式的对抗。而且一些冲锋队成员已经陷入疯狂。已经在城市里横冲直撞，进行示威。我的意思是，他们显然在慕尼黑高喊，元首反对我们，国防军，军队，反对我们。冲锋队，走上街头。展示你们的蔑视。
Now, it's not so much a challenge to Hitler as an expression of their fear and frustration, I think. But Hitler interprets this as the beginning of the coup. And he says, right, we have to absolutely act immediately. So he goes to the Bavarian Ministry of the Interior, which is in Munich, and he summons the local leaders of the SA, who think of themselves, of course, as loyal to Hitler. As his servants. Yes. They're Hitler's, they think of themselves as his keenest, most devoted servants. And I suppose in many cases they are, because lots of them have been with Hitler since the
现在，我认为这与其说是对希特勒的挑战，不如说是他们恐惧和沮丧的表达。但希特勒将其解读为政变的开始。他说，好吧，我们必须绝对立即采取行动。所以他去了位于慕尼黑的巴伐利亚内政部，他召集了当地的冲锋队领导人，他们当然认为自己忠于希特勒。作为他的仆人。是的。他们是希特勒的，他们认为自己是他最热切、最忠诚的仆人。我想在很多情况下他们确实是，因为他们中的许多人从
very beginning. Absolutely. Absolutely they have. This is Hitler's terribleness as a man, Tom, That they come in, you know, Mein Führer, you know, all this kind of meek and mild. And he grips the badges off their tunics and shouts at them, you're under arrest and you're going to be shot. And do you think there's spittle flying in their faces? There's all kinds of spittle, Tom. This is very spittle and spa rich story.
最开始就一直跟随希特勒。绝对是。他们绝对是。这就是希特勒作为一个人的可怕之处，汤姆，他们进来，你知道，我的元首，你知道，所有这些温顺和温和。他从他们的制服上扯下徽章，对他们大喊，你们被捕了，你们将被枪决。你认为他们的脸上会有唾沫飞溅吗？到处都是唾沫，汤姆。这是一个非常多唾沫和多水疗中心的故事。
Yeah. They don't understand. They're terrified and they're dragged off to prison. So then Hitler goes off. He's got another spa town to visit. Yeah, of course he has. He drives off to yet another spa town. This is Bad Wiese on the Lake Degensee.
是的。他们不明白。他们惊恐万状，被拖进了监狱。所以希特勒离开了。他还有另一个水疗小镇要访问。是的，他当然有。他开车去了另一个水疗小镇。这就是泰根湖畔的巴特维塞。
Which is where Röhm has been staying. Where Röhm has been sweating. With his towel and his young lads. Hitler arrives at 6.30 in the morning with a load of SS bodyguards and police. So there's your sign, Tom, that you were talking about in the first half, the institutions that are backing Hitler, the SS and the police.
那是罗姆一直待的地方。罗姆一直在那里出汗。带着他的毛巾和他的年轻小伙子们。希特勒在早上6点30分带着一大批党卫军保镖和警察到达。所以这就是你的信号，汤姆，你在上半部分提到的，支持希特勒的机构，党卫军和警察。
And presumably, so Himmler is now, I mean, he is joined in a bond of blood with Hitler. Yes. Because he's providing Hitler with the means to take the SA out. And hasn't the army given the SS the wherewithal, the weaponry and the trucks and everything? Yes, exactly. The army know this is happening and they're happy with it.
而且大概，所以希姆莱现在，我的意思是，他与希特勒结成了血缘纽带。是的。因为他为希特勒提供了铲除冲锋队的手段。而且军队不是给了党卫军必要的资源、武器和卡车等等吗？是的，完全正确。军队知道这件事正在发生，他们对此感到高兴。
So the army also, their fingers are going to be dabbled in the blood. It's a good point. That from this point onwards, it's not just that they have all, there's a kind of pact of blood against their internal enemies, the communists and the social democrats and so on, but against their own movement that will kind of bind them together. Anyway, Hitler arrives at this Hansel Bauer Hotel, yet another of these kind of spa hotels. Faded, white tablecloths, ticking clock, elderly waiters. As you described in your reading, he bursts him. The first person he goes to is this is this book uh sa senior group leader highness now highness is a very predatory man and he's dragged out of his
所以军队，他们的手指也将沾满鲜血。这是一个很好的观点。从这一点开始，不仅仅是他们所有人，有一种针对他们内部敌人——共产党人、社会民主党人等等——的血盟，而且针对他们自己运动的血盟将把他们团结在一起。总之，希特勒到达了这家汉塞尔鲍尔酒店，又是这些水疗酒店之一。褪色的白色桌布，滴答作响的时钟，年迈的服务员。正如你在阅读中所描述的那样，他闯了进去。他找的第一个人是这个冲锋队高级集团领袖海因斯，现在海因斯是一个非常掠夺性的人，他被从他的
room and he's with this 18 year old boy a blonde haired boy and they're both locked up in a laundry room so this is obviously very bad publicity for the stormtroopers. Then Hitler goes in to see Rome. Rome is kind of, as you described, Rome is a bit bewildered by it, but he's kind of taken out. Kind of sleepy. What's going on? And he just sort of sits in the foyer of the hotel in the reception area, smoking a cigar, like placidly unconcerned, so it appears,
房间里拖了出来，他和一个18岁的男孩在一起，一个金发男孩，他们都被锁在洗衣房里。所以这对冲锋队来说显然是非常糟糕的宣传。然后希特勒进去见罗姆。罗姆正如你所描述的那样，罗姆对此有点困惑，但他被带走了。有点昏昏欲睡。发生了什么事？他只是坐在酒店的大堂接待区，抽着雪茄，看起来平静而漠不关心，
while all this bustle of people being arrested all around him. Because I think Rome just thinks, well, this is probably, who knows what's going on. This is going to sort itself out. Meanwhile, Hitler is kind of rampaging around this spa hotel, bursting into people's bedrooms and shouting, arrested, arrested. That's the worst kind of spa break, isn't it?
当周围所有这些人被逮捕时。因为我想罗姆只是想，好吧，这可能是，谁知道发生了什么。这会自行解决的。与此同时，希特勒正在这家水疗酒店里横冲直撞，闯入人们的卧室大喊，逮捕，逮捕。那是水疗假期中最糟糕的一种，不是吗？
People are being dragged out. They're all locked in the laundry room, which is also kind of the basement. They're being locked in the basement. Shambolically, loads more SA people are arriving because they think there's going to be a big meeting with Hitler. So as they're getting out of their cars, all sorts of smiles and handshakes, Hitler has them arrested.
人们被拖了出来。他们都被锁在洗衣房里，那也是地下室。他们被锁在地下室里。混乱中，更多的冲锋队成员赶到，因为他们以为要和希特勒开个大会。所以当他们下车时，满脸笑容和握手，希特勒把他们都逮捕了。
His men have to charter a coach, I think from Bad Wiese, so it must be the only coach firm in Bad Wiese, to take them all to Munich because they're so kind of ill-prepared. Eventually, Hitler goes back to Munich. He's absolutely frothing at the mouth. People actually do describe spittle flying from his mouth as he talks, Tom. He says, Röhm is guilty, he says, of the worst treachery in world history,
他的手下不得不租了一辆长途汽车，我想是从巴特维塞租的，所以那一定是巴特维塞唯一的长途汽车公司，把他们都带到慕尼黑，因为他们准备得太不充分了。最终，希特勒回到了慕尼黑。他绝对是口吐白沫。人们确实描述了当他说话时唾沫从他嘴里飞出来，汤姆。他说，罗姆犯有，他说，世界历史上最严重的背叛罪，
which is a big claim. He says he's been givenachery in world history, which is a very big claim. Yeah. He says he's been given 12 million marks by the French and he was going to hand Germany over to the French. We must kill all the him and his conspirators. And actually, all Hitler's cronies say, oh, I'd like to kill Röhm, please. I mean, Rudolf Hess, who's like Hitler's poodle, begs him, can I please have the privilege of shooting Röhm? I mean, again, this paints the Nazis in a very bad light, Tom,
这是一个很大的说法。他说他被法国人给了1200万马克，他要把德国交给法国人。我们必须杀死所有他和他那些同谋者。实际上，希特勒所有的亲信都说，哦，我想杀了罗姆，拜托。我的意思是，鲁道夫·赫斯，就像希特勒的哈巴狗，恳求他，我能有幸枪决罗姆吗？我的意思是，这再次把纳粹描绘成非常糟糕的形象，汤姆，
because these are their own comrades. I mean, they're their own partners in evil that they want to turn on. They go through lists and Hitler's kind of crossing them off. But actually, at first, he doesn't order that Röhm be shot. He hesitates. Because presumably it's embarrassing for him. It's incredibly embarrassing.
因为这些是他们自己的同志。我的意思是，他们是他们自己邪恶的伙伴，他们想要反戈一击。他们翻看名单，希特勒把他们划掉。但实际上，起初，他并没有下令枪决罗姆。他犹豫了。因为大概这对他来说很尴尬。这非常尴尬。
Because he's personally invited Röhm back from... Bolivia....La Paz or whatever. Yeah hesitates. Because presumably it's embarrassing for him. It's incredibly embarrassing. Because he's personally invited Ruhm back from La Paz or whatever to run the SA. Exactly. So it reflects badly on his choice of personnel. Hitler is not a sentimental man. I don't think he's going to be sentimental about shooting Ruhm, but I think he knows it's a big step.
因为他亲自邀请罗姆从……玻利维亚……拉巴斯或其他什么地方回来。是的，犹豫了。因为大概这对他来说很尴尬。这非常尴尬。因为他亲自邀请罗姆从拉巴斯或其他什么地方回来管理冲锋队。完全正确。所以这反映了他的人事选择很糟糕。希特勒不是一个多愁善感的人。我不认为他会对枪决罗姆感到多愁善感，但我认为他知道这是一个很大的步骤。
So this has been happening in Munich and most of the targets are the SA. But meanwhile in Berlin, the man in charge there has been Goering. So Goebbels had run Goering that morning with a password, Tom. The password was Colibri, which is hummingbird. And when Goering heard that, he knew that it was time to move. Goering, also an absolutely disgraceful man. He got dressed up, especially in a white tunic, white boots.
所以这在慕尼黑发生了，大多数目标是冲锋队。但与此同时在柏林，负责那里的人是戈林。所以戈培尔那天早上用一个密码给戈林打了电话，汤姆。密码是“蜂鸟”。当戈林听到那个词时，他知道是时候行动了。戈林，也是一个绝对可耻的人。他特意穿上了一件白色束腰外衣，白色靴子。
I mean, a white boots on a man, I think, is never a good look. And sort of blue trousers. So he cuts a very peacock-like figure. And then he's striding up and down his office, going through lists of people. It's very kind of Julius Caesar, Tom. Well, it's the prescriptions. It's the tram for it. He's saying they're going through lists and he's saying, shoot him.
我的意思是，男人穿白靴子，我认为从来都不是一个好的造型。还有某种蓝色的裤子。所以他看起来像一只孔雀。然后他在办公室里走来走去，翻看名单。这非常像尤利乌斯·凯撒，汤姆。好吧，这是处决名单。这是独裁。他说他们正在翻看名单，他说，枪毙他。
Yeah, shoot him. And he's kind of bursting into loud laughter, the thought of all these shootings and all this kind of thing. But all the people who end up being shot, or not all the people, but a lot of the people who end up being shot in Berlin
是的，枪毙他。他发出大声的笑声，想到所有这些枪决和所有这类事情。但所有最终被枪决的人，或者不是所有人，但很多在柏林被枪决的人
are the National Conservatives kind of old order people. Right. And the most significant is General Schleicher, who we mentioned. The previous chancellor. The previous chancellor and his wife. Yeah. An the most significant is General Schleicher who we mentioned. The previous Chancellor. The previous Chancellor
是民族保守派，那种旧秩序的人。对。最重要的人是施莱谢尔将军，我们提到过。前任总理。前任总理和他的妻子。是的。
and his wife. Yeah. An SS squad arrive at their house open the door you General Schleicher yes you are bang, bang
一个党卫军小队到达他们的房子，打开门，你就是施莱谢尔将军吗？是的，你，砰，砰。
and his wife and they're both killed. Papen is not shot is he? Because that would be too embarrassing. He's put under house arrest because he's the Vice Chancellor.
还有他的妻子，他们都被杀了。帕彭没有被枪毙，对吧？因为那太尴尬了。他被软禁了，因为他是副总理。
It would be incredibly embarrassing but his press chief and his speechwriter so Herbert von Bosa and Edgar Jung, who are the people who've been writing his speeches saying, and end the Nazi revolution, let's all calm down. You know, things have gone too far. They are shot. A load of other kind of old Hitler rivals are killed in various ways.
这会非常尴尬，但他的新闻主管和演讲撰稿人，也就是赫伯特·冯·博萨和埃德加·荣格，那些一直为他写演讲稿，呼吁结束纳粹革命、让大家冷静下来的人，你知道，事情做得太过火了。他们被枪毙了。还有一大批希特勒的老对手以各种方式被杀。
Gregor Strasser. Yeah. The guy who was a kind of populist Nazi who had walked out of the... Yes, the rival who'd stepped down. He'd gone off to become a chemist. Yeah. And he gets killed.
格雷戈尔·斯特拉瑟。是的。那个曾走出……是的，那个退出的竞争对手，那个民粹主义纳粹分子。他去当化学家了。是的。然后他被杀了。
And a guy who had... For people who listened to the rise of the Nazis, to the episode about the Beer Hall Putsch, there was a guy who was the big cheese in Munich in those days, who was a guy called Gustav Ritter von Kahr. He's actually hacked to death. He's cut into pieces by the SS, which is a very poor form, Tom.
还有一个……对于听过《纳粹崛起》中关于啤酒馆政变那一集的人来说，当时慕尼黑有个大人物，叫古斯塔夫·里特·冯·卡尔。他实际上是被乱刀砍死的。他被党卫军剁成了碎片，汤姆，这做法太卑劣了。
And you mentioned Roman history. After the murder of Julius Caesar, famously a poet called Sinner is killed in the mistaken belief that he is one of the conspirators. And a very similar thing happens with this, doesn't it? So a music critic called Schmitt, who has the wrong name yes gets killed because they think he's another schmidt and there's also a guy i mean a guy who'd actually helped him to produce to edit mein kampf a guy called um bernard stemfler he is killed as well by a complete accident so in all about 85 people
你提到了罗马历史。在尤利乌斯·凯撒被谋杀后，有个叫辛纳的诗人因为被误认为是阴谋者之一而闻名地被杀。这里也发生了非常相似的事情，不是吗？有个叫施密特的音乐评论家，因为名字搞错了，是的，他被杀了，因为他们以为他是另一个施密特。还有一个家伙，就是那个实际上帮他编辑《我的奋斗》的人，叫伯恩哈德·施滕普弗勒，他也完全是意外被杀的。所以总共大约有85人
are killed. There's a lot of score settling. Poetic justice, one might say. Poetic justice, very good. It's the settling world scores. It's faction fighting, feuding. But it's also a message to two groups. One is the SA.
被杀。这其中有很多清算。有人可能会说是诗意的正义。诗意的正义，非常好。这是在解决旧账。这是派系斗争、宿怨。但这也是给两个群体发出的信号。一个是冲锋队。
You know, you'll get back in line, get back in your box. And the other is the conservatives. And to the army. Yes. And presumably to the whole German people. Absolutely. absolutely so the room just to tie up his fate hitler waits for another um another day but while he's deciding what to do with him there's some talk of a show trial but actually on the sunday the first of july at a garden party would you believe so it's the whole i mean it's the weird way in which there is this sense of faded gentility behind it yeah you know who i'd like to see make a film about this unexpected
你知道，你们得归队，回到你们的位置上去。另一个是保守派。还有军队。是的。大概也是给全体德国人民的信号。绝对是，绝对是。所以，为了了结罗姆的命运，希特勒又等了一天，但在他决定如何处置他时，有一些关于公开审判的讨论。但实际上，在7月1日星期天，在一个花园派对上，你敢信吗？所以，这整个事情，我是说，这背后有一种衰败的贵族气息，真是怪异。是的，你知道我想看谁拍一部关于这个意外的电影吗？
would be uh wes anderson i knew you're gonna say wes anderson he loves a kind of faded spa yeah like the grand budapest hotel something like that yeah well it's a sort of death of stalin you know the armando and uchi film yes there's sort of it's not a comedy because obviously a lot of people die but there is a kind of blackly comic side grotesque side to all this it's a grotesque story in a very grim way anyway at the garden party hitler says fine room's got to go so a load of blokes go to the prison in munich ss mem and they leave room with a pistol they say he should take his own life And they leave him with a newspaper where he can read about his own treachery. And hopefully this will encourage him to take his own life. After 10 minutes, there's been no shots, no sound.
会是韦斯·安德森。我就知道你会说韦斯·安德森。他喜欢那种衰败的温泉酒店，比如《布达佩斯大饭店》之类的。是的，这有点像《斯大林之死》，就是阿曼多·伊安努奇的那部电影。是的，这不是喜剧，因为显然很多人死了，但这一切有一种黑色幽默的一面，怪诞的一面。无论如何，这是一个非常阴郁的怪诞故事。在花园派对上，希特勒说，好吧，罗姆必须死。所以一大群家伙去了慕尼黑的监狱，党卫军成员，他们给罗姆留了一把手枪，说他应该自杀。他们还留给他一份报纸，让他读读关于自己背叛行为的报道。希望这能鼓励他自杀。10分钟过去了，没有枪声，没有声音。
They come back in. Right, no good. As Ian Kershaw says in his book, whether Ruhm had used the 10 minutes to read the newspaper is not known. They take the pistol away and then they come back in. Ruhm by this this stage rather bizarrely has taken his top off and is standing there
他们又进去了。好吧，没用。正如伊恩·克肖在他的书中所说，罗姆是否利用这10分钟看了报纸不得而知。他们拿走了手枪，然后又进去了。罗姆此时此刻非常怪异地脱掉了上衣，站在那里，
sort of topless kind of in a sort of strutting pose. It's not clear whether this is a challenge or whether he wants to he thinks it's better
赤裸着上身，摆出一副昂首挺胸的姿势。不清楚这是一种挑战，还是他认为这样更好，
to greet his death. Well it's a kind of bearing of the chest for a sword. I guess so, yeah. Maybe again it's a kind of echo of a Roman. Yes.
去迎接死亡。嗯，这是一种为了剑而挺起胸膛的行为。我想是吧，是的。也许这又是罗马人的某种回响。是的。
Although rather pathetically. Run me through. Yeah, rather pathetically, rather like Indiana Jones shooting that bloke in Raiders of the Lost Ark. They just shoot him and then that's the end of him.
尽管相当可悲。给我个痛快吧。是的，相当可悲，就像《夺宝奇兵》里印第安纳·琼斯枪杀那个家伙一样。他们只是开枪打死了他，然后他就完了。
He's dead. So the whole thing is done and dusted that day. Hitler's announcement on this is very, the former chief of staff, Worm, was given the opportunity
他死了。所以整件事在那天就彻底了结了。希特勒对此的声明非常简短，前参谋长罗姆被给予了机会，
to draw the consequences of his treacherous behaviour. He did not do so and was thereupon shot. Yeah, very. That's that's all he says branding him with infamy yes so he then goes to his cabinet on the 3rd of july and he says yeah i i didn't have any recourse to legality we've killed all these people and the cabinet they draft a law law for the emergency defense of the state and this law is obviously a total joke because the law says everything Hitler did in the last few days is legal.
去承担他背叛行为的后果。他没有这样做，因此被枪毙了。是的，非常……他只说了这些，给他打上了耻辱的烙印。是的，所以他在7月3日去见内阁，他说，是的，我没有诉诸法律，我们杀了这些人。内阁起草了一项法律，即《国家紧急防御法》，这项法律显然是个彻头彻尾的笑话，因为法律规定希特勒过去几天所做的一切都是合法的。
That's literally the law. So it's a kind of retrospective legal justification for murder, for mass murder. Hitler is clearly anxious about it because it takes him 10 days, another 10 days before he goes to the Reichstag, to the parliament. Because presumably there are lots of people in the Nazi party who've lost friends. Yeah, of course. And who are worried that Hitler has gone mad and is turning on his own. And so Hitler must know this and must worry, do I still have what it takes to command
这简直就是法律。所以这是一种对谋杀、大规模谋杀的事后法律辩护。希特勒显然对此感到焦虑，因为他花了10天，又花了10天，才去国会大厦，去议会。因为大概纳粹党内有很多人失去了朋友。是的，当然。而且他们担心希特勒疯了，正在对自己人下手。所以希特勒一定知道这一点，并且一定很担心，我还有能力指挥
the mass of the party? I guess. I totally agree with you, Tom. You know, the idea of camaraderie and brotherhood, Ruhm, by the way, had incarnated that as part of that front generation. The idea that we are a sort of brotherhood of steel formed in the furnace of the trenches. But the irony of it is that these are people who have absolutely propagated that idea of behaving with steel, of mercilessly crushing enemies, and also have fostered all kinds of grotesque and hideous conspiracy theories. And they have now been monumentally hoist by their own petard. They've been brutally crushed and Hitler is kind of alleging all kinds of dark conspiracies against them. Yes, absolutely. But he's still very, as you say, he's very anxious.
党内大众吗？我想是吧。我完全同意你的看法，汤姆。你知道，同志情谊和兄弟情谊的概念，顺便说一句，罗姆曾作为那一代前线士兵的化身体现了这一点。那种我们在战壕熔炉中形成的钢铁兄弟会的想法。但讽刺的是，这些人正是那些极力宣扬钢铁般行事、无情粉碎敌人，并助长了各种怪诞和丑陋阴谋论的人。他们现在被自己的计谋所害。他们被残酷地粉碎了，而希特勒正在指控他们策划了各种黑暗阴谋。是的，绝对是。但他仍然非常，正如你所说，他非常焦虑。
So you said people lost friends. 13 members of the Reichstag have been killed in this purge. And there are people who were really close friends 13 members of the Reichstag have been killed in this purge. Yeah, right. And there are people who were really close friends with some of the SA men who were in the Reichstag when Hitler gives the speech. And Hitler speaks for two hours. And he's completely unrepentant. And he says, sure, I broke the law. I took the law into my own hands.
所以你说人们失去了朋友。在这场清洗中，有13名国会议员被杀。而且有些人是真正的挚友。在这场清洗中，有13名国会议员被杀。是的，没错。而且有些人是那些在希特勒发表演讲时也在国会大厦的冲锋队员的挚友。希特勒讲了两个小时。他完全没有悔意。他说，当然，我违反了法律。我采取了私刑。
But he says, all I can say is, in this hour, I was responsible for the fate of the German nation. And I was the supreme judge of the German people. I gave the order to shoot those guilty of this treason and i gave the order to burn down to the raw flesh the ulcers of our internal well poisoning and the poisoning from abroad can you have an ulcer of an internal well poisoning i think you can if you're the fuhrer i suppose you probably can because you can do what you like make You can make any mixed metaphor. Because also in that speech, it is not my responsibility to ascertain whether, and if so, which of these conspirators,
但他又说，我只能说，在这一刻，我肩负着德意志民族的命运。我是德国人民的最高法官。我下令枪决那些犯有叛国罪的人，我下令将我们内部毒瘤的溃疡烧毁到血肉模糊，还有来自国外的毒害。你能有内部毒瘤的溃疡吗？我想如果你是元首，你大概可以，因为你可以随心所欲。你可以制造任何混合隐喻。因为在那次演讲中，他还说，我没有责任去查明，如果有的话，这些阴谋家、
agitators, nihilists, and well-poisoners of German public opinion has been dealt too hard a lot. Rather, my duty is to make certain that Germany's lot is bearable. So basically, in other words, I can do what I like because I am German. Yeah, exactly, exactly. Les tassez-moi.
煽动者、虚无主义者和德国舆论的投毒者中，哪一个受到了过重的惩罚。相反，我的职责是确保德国的命运是可承受的。所以基本上，换句话说，我可以随心所欲，因为我是德国。是的，完全正确，完全正确。
And you know what? The public like it i am germany exactly exactly and you know what the public like it the german people by and large i think it's fair to say are pretty happy because a lot of people are deeply resented yeah the essay the bullying the street violence they thought they were thugs football like jumped up football hooligans and finally the fuhrer has cracked down on them good Good for him. Maybe Rome was plotting with the French. Great. No one liked him. Get rid of him. I mean, the thing about the SA is that violence is seen as legitimate. And so if you are, I don't know, an average citizen going out for your Saturday shopping or whatever, and you have gangs of pot-bellied guys in brown shirts
而且你知道吗？公众喜欢这样。我是德国，完全正确，完全正确。而且你知道吗？公众喜欢这样。德国人民总的来说，我认为可以公平地说，他们相当高兴，因为很多人对冲锋队深恶痛绝。是的，那种欺凌、街头暴力。他们认为他们是暴徒，像暴发户一样的足球流氓，终于元首打击了他们，做得好。为他喝彩。也许罗姆在和法国人密谋。太好了。没人喜欢他。除掉他。我是说，关于冲锋队的事情是，暴力被视为合法的。所以如果你是一个普通的市民，周六出去购物什么的，而你看到一群大腹便便、穿着棕色衬衫的家伙，
waving flags and shouting slogans, it's menacing and intimidating. Yeah, exactly. And you want to see it come to an end. Exactly. It's perfectly judged, actually, to appeal to those middle-class people who basically want a quiet life.
挥舞着旗帜，高喊口号，这既具有威胁性又令人胆寒。是的，完全正确。你希望看到这一切结束。完全正确。这其实判断得非常准确，吸引了那些基本上只想过平静生活的中间阶层。
They want order. They want Germany to be great again. They want an end to unemployment and inflation and all the things that they associate with the Weimar Republic. And the fewer strutting bully boys in their little town, as far as they're concerned, the better. So they're delighted. And what about the army? The army are absolutely... I mean, there are lots of winners. So the SS are big winners, of course. Himmler will now accumulate more and more power. He's begun as a bodyguard,
他们想要秩序。他们想要德国再次伟大。他们想要结束失业和通货膨胀，以及所有他们与魏玛共和国联系在一起的事情。至于在他们小镇上昂首阔步的元首恶霸，他们觉得越少越好。所以他们很高兴。那军队呢？军队绝对是……我是说，有很多赢家。所以党卫军当然是大赢家。希姆莱现在将积累越来越多的权力。他最初只是个保镖，
now becomes the kind of, as you said, the Praetorian Guard, unchallenged Praetorian Guard of the Nazi regime, but the army in particular. Wernher von Blumberg, the defense minister, the guy who's supposedly speaking up for the Reichswehr, for the army, he had led the vote of thanks to Hitler in the cabinet meeting. So with all this settled, a month later, the big development development Hindenburg is on his deathbed the president Hitler flew to see him on the 1st of August there's a castle in East Prussia Hindenburg was so far gone that he mistook Hitler for the Kaiser and addressed him as Kaiser I mean what a symbolic moment Tom Hitler goes back to Berlin knowing that Hindenburg only has hours left. And he has all his ministers put their names to a law that says when Hindenburg is dead, to honour him, it's like
现在变成了那种，正如你所说的，纳粹政权不可挑战的禁卫军，但军队尤其如此。国防部长维尔纳·冯·勃洛姆堡，那个据说是为国防军、为军队说话的人，他在内阁会议上带头向希特勒表示感谢。所以随着这一切尘埃落定，一个月后，重大进展，兴登堡病危。希特勒在8月1日飞去见他，在东普鲁士的一座城堡里。兴登堡已经神志不清，他把希特勒误认为是德皇，并称呼他为德皇。我的天，多么具有象征意义的时刻，汤姆。希特勒回到柏林，知道兴登堡只剩下几个小时了。他让所有的部长签署了一项法律，规定兴登堡死后，为了纪念他，就像
retiring the shirt of a footballer. The office of Reich president will be retired. But Dominic, am I right in thinking that the idea for that actually comes from the army, not from Hitler? Well, the idea for the oath comes from the army. So the office is retired, Reich president. There will now just be a Führer, a leader and Reich chancellor. We always say Führer, but actually Richard Evans in his books on the third Reich calls him the leader because, you know, let's sort of demystify the word and think of it as Germans would have thought of it. There is just going to be one leader. And Blomberg and Reichenau, the army chiefs, exactly as you just said, they think, let's bind Hitler to us. And the way we'll do that is we will make everybody in the army
退役足球运动员的球衣一样。帝国总统的职位将被废除。但多米尼克，我理解得对吗？这个想法实际上来自军队，而不是希特勒？嗯，宣誓的想法来自军队。所以职位被废除了，帝国总统。现在只会有一个元首，即领袖和帝国总理。我们总是说元首，但实际上理查德·埃文斯在他的第三帝国书籍中称他为领袖，因为，你知道，让我们把这个词去神秘化，像德国人那样去思考它。只会有一个领袖。勃洛姆堡和赖歇瑙，军队首领，正如你刚才所说，他们想，让我们把希特勒和我们捆绑在一起。而我们这样做的方式就是让军队里的每个人
swear an oath of unconditional loyalty to the leader as supreme commander. And of course, what they don't realize is instead of binding Hitler to the army, they are binding the army to Hitler. Because everything that follows, all the crimes in the Second World War come from this. So it's exactly repeating the mistake that the conservatives have made. Yeah. And thinking that they could use Hitler, they could ride this particular tiger. Yes.
对作为最高统帅的领袖宣誓效忠。当然，他们没有意识到的是，他们没有把希特勒捆绑给军队，而是把军队捆绑给了希特勒。因为随之而来的一切，第二次世界大战中的所有罪行都源于此。所以这完全重复了保守派所犯的错误。是的。以为他们可以利用希特勒，可以驾驭这只老虎。是的。
Later in this series, we will explore a bit more why the army thought that because so much of it is about Hitler's foreign policy ambitions and how much at first it appears that they dovetail with the army commander's ambitions to have a strong army to make Germany great again, all this kind of stuff. But just for the time being, there's a plebiscite, a referendum to approve this change. That happens in the middle of stuff. But just for the time being, there's a plebiscite, a referendum to approve
在本系列的后面，我们将更多地探讨为什么军队会这样想，因为其中很大一部分与希特勒的外交政策野心有关，以及起初看起来这些野心与军队指挥官想要拥有一支强大的军队来使德国再次伟大的野心是多么吻合，所有这些东西。但暂时先这样，有一个全民公投，一个批准这一改变的公投。这发生在八月中旬。
this change. That happens in the middle of August. 90% of the public approve that Hitler is head of state, head of government, leader of the Nazi party. So it's still not quite kind of North Korean levels. Not quite. There's an awful lot of intimidation and whatnot. I mean, Hitler loves a referendum. This is a great series of Spartans and referendums. This is what he's all about. Absolutely. So there's already a cult of Hitler in their brilliant books on the Third Reich. Both Sir Ian Kershaw and Sir Richard Evans talk a lot about this, about the poems, about the Hitler trees, about the Hitler squares and streets.
90%的公众批准希特勒担任国家元首、政府首脑、纳粹党领袖。所以这还不到朝鲜那种水平。没那么夸张。有很多恐吓之类的东西。我是说，希特勒喜欢公投。这是一系列斯巴达式的公投。这就是他的全部。绝对是。所以已经有了希特勒崇拜，关于第三帝国的精彩书籍中，伊恩·克肖爵士和理查德·埃文斯爵士都谈到了很多，关于诗歌，关于希特勒树，关于希特勒广场和街道。
That started in 1933, but in 1934, it really becomes embedded and gathers momentum and it becomes what people call a kind of Fuhrer state. Everything is about the leader. The Fuhrer is the state. Absolutely. He is Germany. It's not that he's representing Germany. He is Germany.
这始于1933年，但在1934年，它真正变得根深蒂固并获得了动力，变成了人们所说的“元首国家”。一切都围绕着领袖。元首就是国家。绝对是。他就是德国。并不是说他代表德国。他就是德国。
He is Germany. Exactly, exactly. The Fuhrerprinzip, the idea of working towards the Fuhrer, all of these ideas. And all of this reaches its kind of symbolic apotheosis. Just a few weeks later, there is an assembly, Tom, of the Nazi party in a great city in southern Germany. And many of our listeners would have seen the extraordinary cinematic images of Hitler walking through the parade grounds, very Star Wars,
他就是德国。完全正确，完全正确。元首原则，为元首工作的想法，所有这些想法。而这一切达到了某种象征性的巅峰。就在几周后，汤姆，在德国南部的一座大城市举行了纳粹党集会。我们的许多听众都看过希特勒走过阅兵场的非凡电影画面，非常像《星球大战》，
past the serried ranks of stormtroopers and Nazi party members and soldiers. Now, what that moment is, we will discuss next time, because I know you're very excited because you're going to be taking us through this story of what happens at Nuremberg in 1934 and the window that that offers us into the world of Nazism, Nazi ideology, Nazi behaviour, Nazi propaganda, all of that stuff. The way, Dominic, that the Nazis set about brainwashing a nation. Brilliant. So that's all very exciting. Now, the great news, we love to brainwash a nation ourselves. In fact, brainwash the world, Tom.
走过成排的冲锋队员、纳粹党员和士兵。现在，那一刻是什么，我们下次再讨论，因为我知道你非常兴奋，因为你将带我们了解1934年纽伦堡发生的故事，以及它为我们提供的观察纳粹主义、纳粹意识形态、纳粹行为、纳粹宣传等世界的窗口。多米尼克，纳粹着手洗脑一个国家的方式。太棒了。所以这一切都非常令人兴奋。现在，好消息是，我们自己也喜欢洗脑一个国家。事实上，洗脑全世界，汤姆。
Well, we love to brainwash a podcast audience, don't we? So if you're in the mood for a little bit more brainwashing, you can hear the rest of this series right now by signing up at therestishistory.com. Now, just to give you a sense of what the series is going to be, there will be episodes on Nazi propaganda and Nazi ideology. There will be two episodes on Hitler's road to war, his plans for war, and also on the Anschluss with Austria, with Hitler's native land. And there will also be an episode about the Nazis and the Jews, and in particular, Kristallnacht, the Night of Broken Glass. And Tom, on that bombshell, we will see you all at Nuremberg. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde.
嗯，我们喜欢洗脑播客听众，不是吗？所以如果你想再多一点洗脑，你可以现在就通过在therestishistory.com注册来收听本系列的其余部分。现在，为了让你了解这个系列的内容，将会有关于纳粹宣传和纳粹意识形态的剧集。会有两集关于希特勒的战争之路、他的战争计划，以及关于与奥地利合并，与希特勒的故乡。还会有一集关于纳粹和犹太人，特别是水晶之夜，破碎玻璃之夜。汤姆，带着这个重磅消息，我们在纽伦堡见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。